Robert Quinn to the Eagles the Eagles  just get better and better when I saw  like the little rumors about them  looking for a restaurant I was like wow  like y'all got Hassan Reddick yeah I got  sweat Brandon Graham you got Fletcher  Cox like I was already thinking like nah  this can't be right because they already  got past rushers and then they went and  got Robert Quinn too like you know the  richest get richer bro and it's just  rude it's just rude like and they ain't  just got like password like no one hit  wonder like Brandon and Fletcher have  been doing it since Jesus was a baby  like them boys just eating bad Robert  Quinn they got old school dogs these  ain't the ones where hey they gonna get  a hangnail or a shoulder gonna hurt or  this and they gonna be down like they  gonna fight through it and them boys  gonna be a problem in the playoffs